[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle sophie faucher je
suis comédienne je suis la fille de jean
et françoise faucher
alors mes parents qui sont tous deux
d'origine française sont arrivés au
québec en 1951 par bateau et avec 400
dollars en poche et l'espoir de faire le
métier d'exercer le métier de comédien
quand on me demande ce que ma mère fait
dans la vie je réponds qu'elle donne et
que le reste du temps elle cherche à qui
donner
il ya quelques mois notre ami alain
labonté a fait paraître un livre qui
s'appelle une âme et sa quincaillerie et
en allant au lancement jeudi alain
pourquoi n'en ferai pas une lecture de
ce livre et c'est lui qui m'a dit est ce
que ça ne dérangerait qu'on fasse signe
à françoise jeudi mais pas du tout et on
enrichit les écrits d'al un des thèmes
qui sont tous d'ailleurs dans son livre
savoirs l'enfance le rapport à la mer la
transmission le legs c'est ça et donc
c'est un vrai bonheur d'être une fois
encore sur scène avec maman ça prend
trois femmes pour faire le monde une qui
danse dans la lumière une autre qui
porte la nuit à bout de bras et enfin
une dernière qui chante des comptines
l'importance de la langue française et
de bien s'exprimer et de trouver le bon
mot ça s'était très présent chez nous je
suis maman à mon tour et ma fille
clémentine aime beaucoup la chanson
anglophone et heureusement lors d'un
séjour en gaspésie elle est revenue de
son été en découvrant les mots de
vigneault de paul piché et ça m'a fait
plaisir parce que ça c'est vraiment
toute ma culture que j'avais peut-être
eu du mal à lui léguer alors merci la
gaspésie
ce que représente la famille pour moi
c'est un clan ce sont mes racines
on dit on ne choisit pas sa famille je
crois que je suis bien tombé
[Musique]